nearly half a million people pass
through this intersection in New York
City's Time Square every day and
starting tonight the giant billboard
behind me will be at the center of their
attention the eight-story tall Mega
screen spans the entire length of a
football field and it's the biggest
billboard New York has ever seen the
digital display is giving Outdoor
Advertising a Hightech twist and with 24
million LED pixels advertisers will be
able to engage with pedestrians
post things like tweets and Instagram
photos update campaigns in real time and
even broadcast promotions to this
massive audience companies are
reportedly paying $2.5 million a month
to occupy this massive billboard so why
is it so valuable well because it's
reaching an audience that only Time
Square can
attract